barrymore it is so good
to be on your show and to meet you i am
such a huge fan
it's unreal that you just even said my
name i'm in shock
oh my god right back at you i
love what you put out into the world
women really embrace and men
i mean by the way you're we're going to
talk about dating because that's just a
fun subject that i want to get into
with you uh right away actually but i
just
first want to preface like how dynamic
you are and how amazing it is that
you're here and i thank you so much
it's just this is this is what i live
for so thank you for everything that you
do
right back at you that means
so much to me i just don't i don't want
this to be a total love fest but like
you just made my life saying that i mean
i've been such a huge fan for so long
and
thank you let's get into it yeah let's
get into dating because that's like one
of my favorite subjects ever to dissect
dating apps thoughts feelings tell me
yeah okay well there's a lot going on
there because guys do not come across
great on dating apps so it's it's not a
fair place
for them and i i'm i don't have a lot to
say about women on dating apps because i
don't um
swipe on women but i'm about to start
because
men are so disappointing on there i
can't
i just the the pictures the the selfies
and i think the real problem is they're
such um visual
apps are so visual that guys have to
have pictures of themselves that
accurately represent who they are
but men don't have as many pictures of
themselves because men don't hang out
with groups of men who are like
dude your eyes look so amazing in the
sunlight right now
is popping so much they don't have a
gaggle of
photographers around them like women do
capturing our best
moments so most men just have to have
like selfies of themselves where they
just a guy taking a selfie i just i it
really is
um kind of repulsive to me or you get
the picture of them on a boat with a
fish
right or everyone is like i was on an
app i went on an app i think you've been
on this app too
where every guy was a surfer a
photographer had a dog and like
definitely their best friend's kid and i
was like wow this is like a cookie
cutter
like it's like the same thing over and
over and over and then
i booked a date with one guy like a fi
finally and then he stood me up
at the exact time we were supposed to
meet and i was like can't you be a jerk
like an
hour before that would have been such a
time saver what was the most shocking
thing that happened to you on a dating
app not that that's shocking i know that
happens all the time
i was more miffed that it was like
at three o'clock when we were supposed
to meet i'm like just do that
we're like wearing the outfit that you
would chose you put so much time into
meeting this person for the first time
it's just so disappointing totally i
felt
so stupid you do you feel dumb and it's
nice to hear that it's happened to you
too because it's
i mean these apps especially the one
you're talking about which i believe is
like the celebrity dating app which has
like
artists i just call it djs jumping off
of yachts because just like
and there are like big high-powered men
and of course i didn't go for any of
those i never have
i was like oh the comedy writer that
sounds fun
yep and and then he i mean i'm sure he
was just extremely intimidated
by you that's always what i convince
myself of when they cancel
i'm just like he was just scared of his
feelings for me
[Music]
i think he's just an uncourteous person
who has
reasons that are completely fine to him
but is going about them all the wrong
way
screw that nikki we gotta face the facts
they're just not showing up it may be
personal it may not be but
you know just whatever like let's not
fool ourselves in the middle of all of
this moving on
i mean you've talked about the beauty
standards because when i did see
the female side of that very dating app
i couldn't believe
the women on it they were drop dead
bikini like there's nothing better than
when the victoria's secrets commercial
comes on when i'm in the couch eating
chinese food i'm like
oh my god oh my god yes i i am
celebrating
you and yet this it's like
of course i'm like my gut hanging out
and the food hanging out of my mouth and
and and that's what that app was it was
all beautiful women in bikinis
and at the same time like i'm like you
know what this is my body i made two
babies
i'm working with what i've got and you
know what screw it
i can't i i love these women in
victoria's secret campaigns
i love these women on this app and i'm
not gonna compare myself to them
but how do you approach it oh okay
so much to unpack there because you're
so right i mean
it is wild the competition on these apps
when you do look into it you're like
i'm competing against the hottest women
in the world like i don't
i don't even know what to do here and
it's so funny because the other night i
was on the app
and there was this guy i think it was
like a guy who's played spider-man
before
you know and i'm i just heard him and i
was just like
please please match you know where you
wait and you go did we link do we like
and as i'm saying please match i was
scraping hummus out of a
party-sized container with my finger
being like please match please
should i go who am i to think i deserve
this person
but the comparing is wild and um i
recently took instagram
off my phone i take a couple days off
because it's just
non-stop uh uh comparing whether it's
good or bad like
even the girls that are like i'm real
and this is my cellulite i'm like
god her cellulite's cuter than mine like
i will find a way
to make myself feel bad and so i have
done this thing that is the best thing
i've done which is
just mute anyone who makes you feel bad
you don't need to block because blocking
tends to
send a message to them if you just mute
anytime you feel bad
someone posts a workout that you're like
oh i didn't work out today
mute someone posted their like glowy
skin me
uh my sister posted that my niece took
her first steps i'm like mewtwo
steps in today and then i don't watch my
knees grow up
so you do the risk of missing moments in
people's lives by muting them but
it's so it's just self-care listen
i love that we're gonna mute for one
second and go to commercial and then
we're gonna come back
back and we're gonna bring your mom into
the folds
yes all right let's do this